Las Vegas, dear! It’s paradise, this is not a metaphor. It’s really not Las Vegas.
Check the map and you will see Paradise. This is also the name you use when visiting and inquiring about the local weather.
The blue part is the Las Vegas city and the pink area is the paradise city: there are almost everything related to Las Vegas.
Even including the market mark!
You may think that paradise is like other cities that have become relatively unknown because of their larger neighbors (eg London and London)
But Paradise City is not a city at all: it is a non-formal area.
What?
A quick review of the political course: Residents living in the city need to comply with the city’s regulations,
And the county law (the largest administrative district below the US state is the county), state law, and national law.
It’s a government that is politicized on every layer of the government’s taxation to enforce current levels of regulation.
But if anyone thinks that this layer of tax is too heavy, he can step on the gas to the fields outside the borders of all cities.
Live like a stubborn individualist: not bound by any regulations
呃... In addition to national law, state law, and county law, we must continue to comply.
But when you move outside the city, you can pay a little less tax and get a little less political.
Because they are in a non-formal area, but when the area develops, the population rises.
People will inevitably want to have police drainage system school rules, etc. So they will soon draft a charter and elect the mayor
Then a new city was born.
The strange thing about Paradise City is that it is not like most non-formal areas.
Most of the tumbleweed that is only scratched and run may have a felt bag (a kind of yurt). This is the equivalent of a Disney World in Paradise City.
Living close to 250,000 people, the population density far exceeds the density of people who usually want to form a city.
But this is not because people in paradise are too troublesome.
Paradise City is almost the only non-organized area that is "officially recognized". So why?
Let's go back to the time when the Mormons moved to this land in the 1880s...
It seems to be too far. Now I jumped to the 1950s when people were conducting nuclear tests in the open areas on the edge of the city.
(Error: Safe and harmless zero pollution mushroom cloud!)
Nevada has just legalized gambling and the gambling empire that is seated in Las Vegas is growing.
Ok, actually, it’s just "just right" outside the edge of the city to avoid paying city taxes. When it comes to serving casinos, it’s enough money.
They can use their private security as a police officer in the real sense
Even if this doesn’t sound like it’s completely deserved, it’s a triad industry.
Now, of course, it’s not the case. The current operators are already two major gaming companies.
Far away now back to the theme in the 1950s Las Vegas Municipality is on the verge of bankruptcy
And the casino that earned a lot of money is on the edge of the city, so the brain is turning around.
Say to the casino in the paradise city area, "Who is it? You are definitely in my jurisdiction. I am the boss. I said that I should pay taxes quickly."
But the casino refused
This dispute can only be solved by the county government that goes to the next level.
By the way, the casino pays taxes directly to the county government, so "surprisingly" the result is
The county government denied the taxation power of Las Vegas to Paradise City
In order to prevent future disputes, the county government officially established this non-established area: Paradise City
All the affairs in the area, Las Vegas has no right to interfere
The county government directly manages the city of paradise and lowers the tax rate. This is why when the new casino is established
Usually choose to be in paradise city instead of Las Vegas
However, if you think that the origin of the city of paradise is only a kind of city-scale tax evasion
Then you are right
Thanks to Audible.com for funding this episode, which is a platform with more than 180,000 audiobooks.
Every year I listen to many audio books and Audible is the platform I choose to use.
Here I would like to recommend a sound novel that I have listened to during my recent trip to Las Vegas.
That is the book of the graveyard book. This is the story of the novel written by Neil Gaimen. I won’t say much if I don’t spoil.
I will tell you that Neil Gaiman is very telling the story and the voice of his narrative fits perfectly with the story.
He gave personality to every character he created in a unique way that only writers have.
If you want to watch interesting and interesting stories, I have to give a thumbs up for this book.
You can go to Audible.com/grey to listen to this book or other readings for free and get a free 30-day experience.
Then go to the free trial and remember that the spelling is GREY, you can get a 30-day trial period and recommend the book of this cemetery.
If you have never walked into the world of audiobooks, now is the time to try.
Translation: Haocheng LONG Review: Tracy YU
As you continue to correct others saying "your holiday is in paradise city instead of Las Vegas"
Las Vegas and Paradise City are located in the Las Vegas Valley
So next time you can still say that you are going to Las Vegas, even if you haven’t actually stepped into Las Vegas.
Because you are in theory going to Las Vegas.